meet Anna sue burry she's a conservative
politician and a vocal opponent of
brexit but this week some of her
opponents came to Westminster and got
more vocal than her this is what has
happened to our country something has
happened here the debate over how
Britain's departure from the EU should
look or whether it should take place at
all now has turned rather ugly this is
the Palace of Westminster it's where
British politicians work and the area
around it is a public street as you can
see anybody can walk down here there can
be demonstrators as well and it's not
unusual on any given day to see a
politician maybe a member of parliament
or even a senior minister simply walk
out of here and towards Abingdon green
here where they might be taking part in
a TV debate or an interview but that
practice is increasingly under threat as
the atmosphere here turns increasingly
tense over the impending brigs it day
and the fact that there is no agreed
plan of action in place this was Anna
super e trying to leave after the
interview the politicians aren't the
only ones getting abuse from agitated
members of the public Sky News anchor
caber Lee was heckled by pro brexit
protesters while live on air and Owen
Jones aide left-wing journalist and
author was taunted by a group of
right-wing protesters the situation
outside parliament has now become an
issue for Parliament to deal with I must
say to the house that it is frankly
intolerable if members of parliament and
journalists go about their business
in fear this situation cannot stand over
60 politicians have written a letter to
London's Chief of Police warning of the
deteriorating security situation around
Parliament and demanding better
protection some politicians have said
that a certain degree of abuse or
heckling simply comes with the territory
of being a elected politician or just a
public figure in a functioning democracy
but the police here now have the rather
difficult task of balancing the freedom
to protest of some with protecting the
safety of others including mine Poli boy
Kayne West Minister well UK historian
and commentator Adil darwish told us he
thinks different opinions should be
celebrated and supported across British
society we have always been divided as a
society our politics is divided our
courts are divided if you look at our
Parliament it's actually two rows
confronting each other but what's new is
now a you have a generation of a very
thin skin as no flakes who are
professionally insulted then you get
also trying to exploit this division to
put your point of view delay breaks it
and so on so so we again journalists are
to blame for playing this one rather
than actually say reminding people say
they're women we can always have fun we
can always sort of try to ridicule each
other ideas but within civilize the way
now it's escalated beyond actually any
recognition and they said lesson for
every body that you should know love
when your opponent's being verbally
attacked and verbally abused we should
always stand up and say yes we have
freedom of expression but also freedom
to express our views without being
assaulted
you